Welcome to the GopherTrunk Field Guide —
the video edition.
This course is the trunked radio pillar:
the concepts that let many users share a
small pool of channels, explained one idea
at a time.
Here is the route.
We start with trunked radio itself — the
architecture, and why statistics make it
work.
Then the control channel, the data stream
that coordinates everything.
Then talkgroups, the virtual channels you
actually listen to.
Then channel grants, the messages that
start every call.
And finally FDMA and TDMA, the two ways
calls share the spectrum.
Every segment stands alone — each one
starts from its own definition, so you can
jump straight to the idea you need.
And every segment has a full written
article in the Field Guide at gophertrunk
dot org, linked below, with diagrams,
variants, and sources.
That's the map.
Let's start where the whole idea starts:
with the problem of too many groups and
too few frequencies.